i want to bring up a story we have here
this is really cool and uh
i was i was so i saw the story over at
daily mail it's body cam
captures moment cop single-handedly
lifts
over turned car off virginia mother
thrown outside vehicle after crash
and first of all i was like dude that is
cool
a cop to save a woman lifted the vehicle
by himself
amazing wow now i think it was upside
down and he like was able to push it off
and roll it or something
but i was also thinking like you rarely
see these stories go viral
exactly i was just sitting here thinking
the same thing it's it's you know you've
got all of this anti-police rhetoric
every single day which is of course why
you're seeing uh
a violent crime rise in in a city like
philadelphia
it's it's and you talk about like
removing a cop's qualified immunity
like give give your your viewers an
example of what that means like
as a soldier on the battlefield you've
got protection in that regard too so in
other words if one of my soldiers gets
injured i run out and i try to
you know give for render first aid maybe
they got a sucking chest wound
and i we we saved their life put them on
a helicopter get them back to the states
and maybe they have an issue with their
lungs
right like should that soldier be able
to sue the
the federal government or the department
of defense because he was wounded on the
battlefield right now
it's illegal you can't do that because
at the end of the day like
you're in combat like you're surrounded
by death and destruction like you're
doing the best you can
so the government is immune from the dod
or
or the army in general so what does this
mean for the cop well the cop
what it means for the cop is is that you
know if a cop is out there like just
trying to do their job
and they they can be sued by they can be
sued by anybody for doing
anything 800 absolutely so it's like
defunding you're a hundred percent right
it's like defunding the police without
actually
def they're all i mean it's all about
gonna be yes
i think that that one's a challenge
because i'm not entirely sure you know
how you deal with it
just not being able to sue maybe there
should be a higher burden or something
because
when we had i think chauvin they said he
had you know like 19 complaints or
something out of 18 years and i'm like
actually sounds pretty good you'd think
a cop is like i'm writing a ticket i'm
gonna complain about you
it's like everyone's gonna complain
nobody wants to get pulled over nobody
wants to get arrested the point the
point
what we're talking about though is like
to your point is like all we hear is the
negative
but cops i they are out there every
single day putting it all on the line
doing good things for people
and this story is just one example of it
it's a cool story
let me show a little bit so this is a
vehicle flipped over
and the officer was able to lift it up
to save the individual
i mean i'll just give you the the bullet
points here they say gloucester county
sheriff deputy
john holt rescued the woman when she had
been trapped under the sunroof of the
car after it wrecked on may 7th
her young son is heard desperately
crying out mommy mommy before the deputy
was able to rescue her
the incredible video has since gone
viral after being shared
on tuesday by the sheriff's office with
more than 84 000 views on facebook
that's not viral 84 000 views not viral
you can you can you can go on twitter
and there's a video of some random dude
farting it's got a million views don't
talk about viral
they say he recently received a local
and regional top cop
award for saving a disabled young girl
and a woman from a burning home last
march
but i i still see this and i'm like i've
heard these stories about how people can
can muster up inhuman strength because
humans are actually much stronger
than we we are on a daily basis there's
i don't i don't know that's how it works
but i read there's like a limiter
that humans only exert around 20 percent
of their actual muscular capacity
how do you know this stuff as i'm on
reddit
because someone's like did you use it
i'm just like i don't know if it's true
you gotta you gotta affect me on this
one
but it's something like we have we
there's a limit to how much strength we
can use unless we get our adrenaline
pumping and there's a live or die moment
because your muscles start destroying
themselves when you exert too much
but what you hear these stories about
like a mother and she's able to
like pull her daughter up like hanging
from with one arm and
lift them up and then pull herself up to
save a child or like lift a vehicle
these are cool stories and so i want to
make sure like we're not always just
just stewing in the negativity but
there's some there's still some
negativity here
what happens on facebook i saw a video
go
going viral today and it was like it was
on reddit and it was like
uh cop kicks a man in the head even
though he's already
subdued and is being arrested and it was
true there's a video of a guy's on the
ground his hands behind his back the
cops cuffing him and a cop runs up and
just punts his head
and i'm like now why would that cop do
that more importantly
i've seen this video a thousand times
because it gets recycled
they put it up it gets traffic they put
it up again this story 84 000 views a
cop lifted a vehicle to save a woman
how many times is that going to get
recycled it's not it only got 84 000
views i see this video on reddit it's
got a million views in a week 11 million
views again in a month they'll have a
million views again
because they keep sharing the same
things over and over and over the social
media companies
and search engines control what you see
and when
you control the flow of information you
control what people
think in in certain regards and now
people hate the police
i mean look you look at the algorithms
and what they've produced over the past
10 years it sounds like jack dorsey and
mark zuckerberg purposefully want to
destroy this country
they have driven people insane they
they there are people who literally
believe the cops go around hunting black
people
they actually believe that so prageru
they send out will wit will goes to like
venice skate park in in california
you know same skatepark we're talking
about just a moment ago and he asked
three young black men how many
unarmed black men do they think had been
killed in the past year and they're like
thousands
like it's like 19. it's bad like 19
people but we're in a country of 320
million people
was it 375 million police interactions
19 of which
resulted in unarmed black men being shot
and killed and of those
some of them are actually justified in
like a guy was trying to run someone
over so he's not armed but
he's using a car or they're about to
attack someone or they're about to like
they grab some by the throat and they're
beating them or pummeling them or
sometimes
it's it was it was a it was a wrongful
you know shooting in in some
circumstances
they're all bad we don't want people to
die of course not right but because of
social media
because they weaponize this stuff
everyone goes insane and don't get me
wrong
it goes the other direction too what you
see on the left today
is i think social media has has helped
form the culture war into fact in a
faction
into factions of people who blindly just
believe whatever the media says no
matter what
and the people who for the most part
distrust the media with a decent portion
who distrust no matter what the media
says they'll distrust them
so you end up with people who believe
the earth is flat or who believe in
these weird
conspiracy theories about lizard people
because they go online and they can find
the stuff and they believe it
and i hear some of the craziest stuff
when i when i read when i read the news
but do those people have any
institutional power do people who think
the earth is flat
are they in congress no well people
believe in god i mean that's almost as
ridiculous
no absolutely not there's zero evidence
ever i mean you want you're gonna ignite
a whole other conversation it is it is
it's a big conversation but
there's not zero evidence the issue is
if you don't talk about
theism and like religious text and
doctrine i'm not talking about that
um so i'm talking about people you could
literally you could literally climb a
tower and measure the the shadows and
calculate the circumference of the
planet
like that dude uh eratosthenes did in
one bc
because you can disprove the earth the
earth is flat it's different than you
can prove
the earth is round right believing in
god and faith-based things and
and and you know having philosophy is an
entirely different discussion lizard
people
i mean right there's there's there's no
evidence
lizard people is dramatically different
from believing in god dude but it's
dramatically similar
no it's not yeah there's just no
evidence i'm eggnog i mean
you're you're you're you i i don't want
to deviate yeah and derail the
conversation you're confusing
philosophical and theological
conversations with text
and and and and fairy tales there's text
about the flat earth that's where it
comes from yeah but there's no
scientific thing
okay yeah it's not it was before science
was invented people go online
and they watch insane videos about
insane things and they believe it they
go online and they read books about
you know they see things about critical
race theory it's insane and they believe
it
and that's bad zealotry and
fundamentalism all of these things are
problems
they exist so the problem is we need
critical thinking instead we get
critical theory
and then people just blindly follow and
march off cliffs like lemmings
well and it's it's it's it's it's it's
not just social media right like a
much of the sort of propaganda that is
pushed on people on social media is also
taught in schools and so we're teaching
our kids from a very young age in our
public schools like critical race theory
for example that
you know teaches kids to dislike each
other or
think about each other based on the
color of their skin
or hate their country or hate their
country uh or think that america is
fundamentally evil or bad and this this
is a problem and not only is it
happening in our schools now it's
happening in our military
right like there are there are
ideological purity tests for people the
miller teaching critical race theory in
the middle and the military and i'm
telling you
look i got out i was medically retired
um
in 2010 so it wasn't that long ago i
mean we're talking like 11 years ago i
got out this stuff was
nowhere to be found in the military
because
it ain't about you right in the military
one of the things they teach you with
basic is that
it's okay all of this like you know it
ain't about you anymore so we're going
to shave your head we're going to put
you in a uniform
we're only as fast this team is only as
fast as its slowest person we're all
going to make our bed the same way our
lockers are all going to be the same way
because what they're doing there
is creating they're whittling down the
individual identity
and they're creating a collective right
and that and look past our differences
work together but that but that that
that sounds a bit like what the critical
theorists do
but that's that's not but but see the
the difference is
is that the focus in critical race
theory is
only on our differences right that's
that's a fundamental difference
and in the military that can get you
killed because the goal of critical
theory is to destroy
it's to deconstruct yes they genuinely i
look i i know i've known many of these
people for a long time
and they have routinely expressed their
desires to destroy the system
they just want to watch some say i just
want to watch it burn some say from the
ashes of the old we will build the new
that's the idea so critical theory is
their means to an end they think
they will just they will deconstruct
everything make it impossible to have
communications
they will fracture any ability for a
collective identity within the united
states
and after that it's rubble then they'll
come back with their you know
whatever communism socialism we were
always taught growing
up that the reason why america was such
a wonderful player
part of the reason was that we have
people from all over the world that come
here
to live the american dream be free
give a good life to their kids why
because america is a melting pot do you
remember that do you ever were you ever
taught that as a course the great
american melting pot yes
well america right now it's a melting
pot that's not melting
and that that that's a pretty that's a
problem critical theory is trying to
re-emulsify the differences whereas we
used to believe that you throw everybody
in the melting pot and you get a nice
fondue with a bunch of different flavors
they're actually trying to reverse
entropy to get the pepper jack back
out of the food compare you just compare
america and the american people to
fondue i've never i've never said
melting pot
i've never had fondue it's good it's a
melting pot what is it it's melted
cheese
i don't talk about derailing the
conversation i'm sorry but i don't know
what's wrong with this
fondue it's a melting pot my diet you
get a little thing
you throw cheddar and you throw in swiss
and pepper jack and whatever
and then you turn it on and it melts all
of the cheeses together and then you dip
stuff in the cheese it sounds like
something that you it sounds like
something that you would like really
like you it's incredible
we got we have one on the counter right
porsche of course you do of course
or you can take like oil some garlic
some vinegar soy sauce and then boil it
and you put the meat in it
you blend everything it's just a pot
fruit this sounds a little adventurous
to me like i
like if you if i go to a restaurant you
give me dino chicken nuggets some tater
tots i am good
here's the i eat like a two-year-old the
great american men i don't know how
we're here i don't know how we got it
it's a great american
listen great american melting pot right
you get some
some chihuahua cheese from mexico you
get some american cheese from america
you get some
some good uh dubliner from from ireland
i think it's from ireland
and then uh you you throw it all in a
pot it all melts together
and we're like this is some great cheese
what is it i just mixed a bunch of stuff
together i do it all the time
i take like colby jack and pepper jack
and swiss and havarti and i just blended
up and make nachos
and i'm like isn't it amazing that you
can get this great blend of cheeses
you ever have four cheese pizza could
you what like dizzorno
yeah you go you're like i'll take the
four cheeses
now imagine if you're hanging out with
someone they were like can i take the
ricotta
out of this ricotta out of this pizza
and you're like it's all blended
together yeah i know but
we should remove it yeah at some point
like that's critical theory or i only
want to eat the r
i only want to eat that little bit yeah
yeah no
uh and the rest is wasted after after
you only yeah mozzarella supremacy needs
to end
our pizzas should have different cheeses
so get the mozzarella out you're like
but we melted it all together well in
the future let's actually put block so
that your pizza is actually
i mean this what you're saying is
accurate i mean they're actually like in
certain colleges they're having
graduation i mean they said dorms this
is
like this is not progressive this this
is like to be a progressive in today's
day and age is actually to be a
regressive
like they're going backwards in time
with this stuff but they love using
language
that's why so i see on twitter they're
like oh right
critical race theory is diversity and
inclusion
there's a reason why they say diversity
inclusivity and equity
are you gonna you gotta tell me right
like diversity inclusivity and equity
oh oh i see what you did i didn't do
that
well i just i didn't even realize it i
didn't diversity inclusivity and equity
these are the things they they're
calling for they're literally saying die
i don't know why they do that well they
could not do that they do
use they like they do control the left
does an extraordinary job
at controlling the language right and
uh that's what that's what we're talking
about now like critical race theory
is is inherently bad for the country as
we mentioned it teaches people to hate
their country but they mask it and
shroud it in words that sound
nice they literally create diversity
inclusivity and equity positions
could you imagine someone hiring a
special position a company
and they say this is our die manager die
and it's like it's a little it's a
little weird yeah well hopefully they
don't use the acronym or come up with
something different or
reshuffle the words but it's almost like
they're laughing in our faces you've got
why why do these why are companies
hiring diversity officers
what does that mean it doesn't mean
anything double speak it's 1984
right it's it's basically in in
communist china
companies have to have the commun
communist party member in the united
states
they're just getting these companies to
create a a
an an ideological dogmatic
job that makes no sense other than to
indoctrinate the employees
what what i'll say is that you know
specifically in the context of the
military because i've been speaking out
about this but like
diversity is is a it's a good thing like
in my platoon we were very diverse and
because we were very diverse we had a
multitude of ideas that were brought to
the table all the time but
you have to take diversity is is it's i
don't want to say it's
it's meaningless but it's you have to
have
unity beyond the diversity in order for
it all to work
yeah right diversity is a result of
empowering individuals
with opportunity the diversity then
comes from that you can't
force i mean if you force superficial
diversity you're going to end up with
homogeneous
homogeneity homogeneity that's it
yeah and that's what we're seeing that's
why they call it critical race theory
it's got a term that well it's
critical critical theory so one of the
other mistakes people make is they say
critical race theory and they cut out
the rest of it it's like no it's
critical theory in general
yeah there's this critical gender theory
there's critical literature and
critical literature theory and i would
say that true diversity is actually a
huge strength because it brings people
together you're capitalizing on the
things that make them
different that bring those good strong
components to your team
of course for example in your platoon
that you were leading
you need all these people with different
strengths of course actual diversity is
pivotal it's great exactly yes but
you're unified
right right you're unified yes we're all
different but that's part of what makes
america great yes we're all different
but we bring
aspects of our culture that we love and
we're proud of and we integrate into
american society and then we share those
blessings with other people
right like that's what makes this
country great that's why people
risk their lives to come here from cuba
and shark infested waters
they don't come here because they
believe america is is fundamentally evil
they come here because they believe
america is free
and their kids can have a better life
than them but the new
the the radical left does not believe
that they're taking this country
back in the wrong direction and we have
to stop them
we have to stop them thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you